PROFESSOR THANKS FOR JOINING US
AND CONGRATS ON THE BOOK.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS EVERY
INTENTION OF TAKING OVER
HEALTHCARE AND ENERGY.
BUT NOT STOPPING THERE.
THEY LIKE TO NATIONALIZE
PARENTING TOO.
ELIZABETH WARREN AND KAMALA
HARRIS HAVE ENDORSED PLANS FOR
SOCIALIZED CHILD CARE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE REST OF THE PARTY WON'T BE
FAR BEHIND WHY HAVE PARENTS
RAISE THEIR OWN KIDS WHEN THE
STATE CAN DO IT?
THIS IS THE EXECUTIVE EDITOR THE
FEDERALIST AND THE MOTHER OF
FIVE ALL 8 OR YOUNGER.
I AM GLAD YOU GOT A BREAK.
I LOVE YOUR STUFF ON THE
FEDERALIST.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
TELL US WHY WE SHOULD BE
SKEPTICAL OF SOCIALIZING DAY
CARE?
>> THE FIRST IS THAT'S NOT WHAT
MOTHERS WANT FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND SECONDLY IT'S NOT IN THE
BEST LONG-TERM INTEREST OF
CHILDREN.
THE BEST RESEARCH WE HAVE ON
CHILD CARE THE MORE LITTLE
CHILDREN ARE AWAY FROM THEIR
MOTHERS AND THE EARLIER THEY DO
THAT AND THE LONGER, THE MORE
BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS THEY HAVE
LONG-TERM.
ALSO MOTHERS THEMSELVES JUST
WANT TO BE WITH THEIR KIDS.
THEY LOVE THEM.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE HEALTH OF
OUR SOCIETY TO BREAK THE
MOTHER-BABY BOND.
WE SHOULD BE DO EVERYTHING TO
PROTECT IT.
>> Tucker: THE COUNTER ARGUMENT
THAT THE LEFT AND MANY
CONSERVATIVES MAKE WHICH IS THAT
BUSINESS DEMANDS A HIGHER LABOR
FORCE PARTICIPATION RATE FOR
WOMEN.
IT'S GOOD FOR THE GDP FOR MOMS
TO LEAVE THEIR SMALL CHILDREN.
OUTSOURCE CHILD REARING TO
PEOPLE FROM FOREIGN COUNTRY AND
GET BACK TO WORK TO SERVE GLOBAL
CAPITALISM.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
ARGUMENT?
>> THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
ECONOMY IS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES?
WE DON'T HAVE FAMILIES IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT THE ECONOMY.
WE HAVE THE ECONOMY TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES.
WE SHOULD NOT PUT THE SHORTTERM
INTERESTS OF TODAY'S BUSINESSES
FIRST.
WE SHOULD PUT THE LONG-TERM
HEALTH OF OUR SOCIETY FIRST.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR OUR SOCIETY IF
MORE CHILDREN ARE COMMITTING
CRIMES WHEN THEY GROW UP AS
HAPPENED IN QUEBEC WHEN THEY
IMPLEMENTED A FULL DAY CARE
PROGRAM THERE.
THE CHILDREN ARE MORE AGGRESSIVE
AND HAVING MORE SPECIAL NEEDS
PLACEMENT.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS THINK
ABOUT WHAT IS MOST SUSTAINABLE
FOR SOCIETY AND BUSINESS PLAYS A
ROLE BUT IT IS NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
>> Tucker: EVERY SURVEY SHOWS
THAT MOST PARENTS WOULD LIKE TO
RAISE THEIR OWN KIDS WHEN THEY
ARE LITTLE.
IF I WAS RUNNING A MITT --
POLITICAL PARTY I WOULD MAKE IT
SO YOU COULD LIVE ON ONE INCOME
AND RAISE YOUR OWN KIDS.
IT SEEMS SIMPLE.
WHY IS NO PARTY DOING THAT?
>> BECAUSE THE PARTIES ARE
LISTENING TO THE POLSTERS RATHER
THAN TO THE PEOPLE CLOSE TO THE
FAMILIES AND THE CHILDREN.
IF YOU TALK TO LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE-CLASS MOTHERS, THEY CALL
IT A MARK OF LUXURY TO DEVOTE
MORE TIME TO FAMILY AND LESS TO
PAID WORK OUTSIDE OF THE HOME.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT MOTHERS
ARE LOOKING FOR.
I AM A MOTHER.
THAT'S WHAT I AM LOOKING FOR.
TO BE MORE WITH MY FAMILY.
WHEN WE ARE INVESTING IN OUR
CHILDREN, WE INVEST IN THE
LONG-TERM HEALTH OF SOCIETY.
MOMS OUGHT TO BE LISTENED TO.
WE ARE VOTERS AND THE PEOPLE
SHAPING THE NEXT GENERATION.
IF WE ARE NOT THERE THOSE KIDS
WILL HAVE A GREATER NEED THAT
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE THERE IF MOMS
WERE ALLOWED TO DO WHAT WE WANT
TO DO.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
ALL WE HEAR IT CORPORATE
PROPAGANDA FROM ELIZABETH WARREN